we all want to be successful in life and
when we see successful individuals we
wonder what made them successful
is it luck or they have something we
don't have
upon studying the life of successful
persons it is found that most of the
successful persons have some traits that
help them to excel in life
here are three traits of a successful
persons that you can learn and hopefully
be successful in life
one adaptability
adaptability is the ability to change
and adapt in response to new information
situations or environments
it is a trait that is often associated
with successful individuals as it
enables them to be flexible and
open-minded and to adjust their
strategies and approaches as needed in
order to achieve their goals
adaptability can be a valuable trait in
a variety of situations including in the
workplace in personal relationships and
in life in general
for example a person who is adaptable
may be able to quickly learn new skills
and Technologies and to adapt to
changing job roles or industry trends
in a personal relationship adaptability
can help individuals to navigate
conflicts and challenges and to find
ways to compromise and work together
having the trait of adaptability can
also help individuals to be more
resilient and to handle stress and
adversity
by being open to new ideas and
approaches and by being willing to try
new things individuals who are adaptable
can learn from their experiences and
grow as individuals
overall adaptability is a valuable trait
that can help individuals to be more
successful and fulfilled in their
personal and professional lives
2. communication
effective communication skills are a
trait of successful individuals because
they enable them to convey information
ideas and emotions to others in a clear
and concise manner
they are able to use language that is
appropriate for the audience and the
context and to listen actively and
attentively to the receiver in order to
understand their perspective and respond
to any questions or concerns
having good communication skills is
important for many reasons
it can help individuals to build and
maintain relationships to share
information and ideas and to express
their thoughts and feelings
it can also help them to succeed in
their education and careers as it is
often a key skill that is valued by
employers and educators
for example a successful person with
strong communication skills may be able
to persuade others to support their
ideas to negotiate effectively or to
give clear instructions and guidance to
their team
they may also be able to build trust and
credibility with others which can
enhance their reputation and their
ability to achieve their goals
overall effective communication skills
are a valuable trait of successful
individuals because they enable them to
convey information and ideas clearly and
concisely and to build and maintain
relationships with others
they are an essential skill that is
important for personal and professional
success
three perseverance
perseverance is the trait of continuing
to pursue a goal or objective despite
obstacles setbacks or difficulties
it is the willingness to put in the
effort and the time to achieve a goal
even when the going gets tough
perseverance is an important trait
because it enables individuals to
overcome challenges and setbacks and to
keep moving forward towards their goals
it is often associated with successful
individuals as it allows them to be
persistent and resilient in the face of
obstacles and difficulties
having the trait of perseverance can
also help individuals to be more
resilient and to handle stress and
adversity
by continuing to pursue their goals even
when things are difficult they can learn
from their experiences and grow as
individuals
perseverance is a trait that can be
developed and improved over time
it involves setting goals making a plan
and being persistent and resilient in
the face of challenges
it also involves being open to learning
and growth and being willing to adjust
and adapt as needed in order to achieve
success
overall perseverance is a valuable trait
that can help individuals to be
successful and fulfilled in their
personal and professional lives
it enables them to overcome obstacles
and setbacks and to continue pursuing
their goals even when the going gets
tough
hope you learned something new